[Musique]
bonsoir martin m'a collé merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france un
troisième confinement viens d'entendre
quelques réactions mitigées des anglais
mais on imagine tout le même
autrement je peux cela doit être un coup
de massue oui c'est très noble de bain
c'est une nouvelle terrible image riche
une seule le premier ministre a dit au
pays que toutes les écoles pouvaient
ouvrir directement que la situation
n'était pas si terrible et le lendemain
d'un petit tout le pays et maintenant
j'en plus finement un confinement plus
drastiques coller le but et c'est dans
plus d'un million de personnes ont
contracté le virus
les hôpitaux sont submergés chaque
muscle ou les écoles du primaire et du
secondaire seront fermés jusqu'au 15
février
on espère que ce jour là on pourra ré
ouvrir les écoles c'est en tout cas ce
que le gouvernement espère il espère que
d'ici au 15 mars qu à sion sera meilleur
et que les écoles pourront griller robot
cela a causé beaucoup de problèmes pour
les parents notamment les parents qui
travaillent
qui va s'occuper des enfants de plus
cela renforce les inégalités entre les
élèves de foyers plus riches et de
foyers plus pauvres à beyrouth je veux
ou parce que les familles aisées
lorsqu'elle met en place un
apprentissage à distance passé 35
minutes de plus par jour sur le travail
scolaire que les familles pauvres
enfin les moins fortunés
en plus cela va accroître les inégalités
et c'est un problème majeur gouvernement
espère qu'ils pourront tester étudiants
les enfants afin de savoir qui a les
férus sommes pas mais les statisticiens
je dis que le test elle n'est pas très
précis et on pourrait donc tirer
certains élèves qui n'ont pas le virus
alors qu'en fait ils sont contagieux le
gouvernement essaye de faire en sorte
que 13 millions de personnes le plus 15
millions de personnes soient vaccinés
d'ici à six semaines ton et les
professeurs c'est très important pour
les écoles donc le but est que tous les
personnels enseignants soient vaccinés
afin qu'il n'y ait plus de transmission
du virus sur les étudiants en attendant
60000 contaminés aujourd'hui c'est un
record pour le royaume uni
on imagine que c'est un terrible aveu
d'impuissance
aujourd'hui de la part du gouvernement
qui vous nous disiez très bien a fait
volte-face finalement en quelques jours
cela doit être extrêmement anxiogène de
sentir que les autorités ne peuvent plus
rien entre ce virus
le gouvernement a accepté le fait que ce
virus est incontrôlable s'est carrément
que c'est une mutation du virus en
mesure de contrôler la scène
poste c'est la vaccination je donne le
sein de la population et du révolu c'est
65 millions et comment vaccination des 5
millions de personnes ce n'est pas
possible il faut prioriser certaines
personnes les personnes de plus de 60
ans
par exemple sont prioritaires mais des
personnels des hôpitaux les infirmiers
les docteurs sont aussi une priorité
ils doivent être testés et vacciner
d'abord et ensuite comment décider qui
viendra ensuite les personnes âgées ou
les jeunes je buvais les jeunes tease
nous n'offrions être vaccinés car
ensuite nous pourrons retourner à
l'école donc c'est vraiment un très gros
problème pour le gouvernement
comment décider qui ira d'abord tenu que
c'est vraiment un sujet de paul une
polémique qui n'est pas près de
s'éteindre et qui semble insoluble
martin m coli pardonnez moi de vous
couper mais d'autant que le deuxième
problème qui se pose c'est au royaume
uni comme ça va venir évidemment en
france c'est déjà le cas en allemagne à
la question du manque de doses de
vaccins d'ailleurs le royaume uni a fait
un pari audacieux sur ce point il a
décidé de retarder l'injection de la
deuxième dose ce qui n'est pas
recommandé par le fabriquant un phaser
comment accueille cet initié comment les
pardons les anglais accueillent cette
initiative de la part de boris johnson
qui est quand même assez surprenante en
tout cas audacieuse de la promenade au
se fait là car cela les protégera ceux
qui n'ont pas été vaccinées du tout
préféré recevoir une dose donc c'est
encore une fois une question de priorité
à qui doit-on la priorité qui passe
d'abord qui passe ensuite en troisième
voire en quatrième place
donc c'est un conflit et c'est un
véritable dilemme des gens acceptent
l'idée que le personnel sanitaire les
personnels des hôpitaux ou des maisons
de retraite doivent passer en premier et
ensuite il ya les enseignants si on ne
vaccine pas les anciens mais on ne peut
pas rouvrir les écoles de manière
parfaitement sécuritaire donc la seule
solution c'est plus de vaccins
distribués plus rapidement mais comment
les répartir dans le pays très
rapidement quand on ne veut pas
simplement les mettre dans un camion et
les envoyer là où on veut il y à un
système logistique à garder ils sont
besoin d'une certaine température et je
pense que l'armée serait la meilleure
solution car c'est une administration
extrêmement efficace qui peut
transporter le vaccin dans le pays de
manière très rapide et efficace thriller
que projet pourrait accélérer le
processus
invaincus tout le monde espère qu on ne
va pas se retrouver face à une véritable
pénurie
cependant c'est inévitable et à certains
endroits il n'y aura plus de vaccins et
il faudra donc obtenir de nouveaux
vaccins quelque part donc c'est vraiment
un casse tête chinois pour le
gouvernement très difficile à résoudre
la seule chose qu'on puisse faire le
premier ministre s'est demandé à sa
population d'être raisonnable de garder
son sang froid
je veux jouer de donner la priorité à
ceux qui jouaient ce sont des
professionnels de la santé aux
enseignants et au personnel de maison de
retraite et ensuite ce sera au tour des
jeunes personnes qui elle demande à être
vaccinés immédiatement pouvoir par
exemple retourner à l'école
titus merci beaucoup martin à macau les
analyses politiques d'avoir été avec
nous pour vu de l'extérieur ce soir